thank you
[Music]
and so you guys heard what about Tom
Brady right you heard
about what about Tom Brady what about
him I was making out with his kids he's
gonna wait what that's really the thing
what allegedly are we have proof he did
KISS it on his kid pretty good in a
documentary and a lot of people were
like that was a clip that was going
viral they almost kissed him on the lips
that was a long time ago it was a long
time ago but that's not what this is
about but I do love to rub it in that he
is a kid kisser come on Mr has nothing
to do with that I like to open the
article on that
um so you know context-wise
so his ex-wife they got a divorce right
him and Gisele bettions yeah Legends
they got a divorce and now Giselle is
taking some Revenge pics uh-oh post them
on social media this is what you're
missing man
yes sir Revenge pics definitely Revenge
that's good and so you know everyone in
the media is talking about you ever
taken any Revenge picks Colleen this is
a 50 year old woman
she's 50. that's great that's a Revenge
pick a real revenge pick is hurting with
Pete Davidson
oh [__] it's gonna happen to you too
Colleen you can yeah yeah you don't your
time is coming yeah he's coming for all
of us frankly yeah honestly I'll [__]
give it to him whoa what you're just
gonna give it to the guy you're gonna
give him he's like I don't want it she
looks great gosh it looks great she
looks incredible I like photos
really get in there Anthony 50 years old
comment sure 50 on there just say that
because you're 50. hey you're 50.
time let's set it like 50 times already
so we're like wow she's
she's a two
wait 42 of 50 are bigger
they're very different it's so different
how the hell that's like super different
you're supposed to round up from five
she's 73. that's also a key decade where
you look drastically different depending
on which one mama two she had two kids
snaking out between those legs sneaking
out dude yeah
dropping out of there she gave birth to
him she looks 42 she doesn't she doesn't
look 50 because she looks late 30s early
40s or something okay I correct my
statement I mean she looks good there is
something very very uh wonderful about
like when people like split up from a
relationship right like with guys
oftentimes they start going to the gym
they start getting all fit same thing
with girls they're starting they change
their hair color or whatever you know
after they break up somebody so it's
like you should stay single because you
don't let go that's the club the moral
of the story why are you guys doing it
after the fact you're single you should
have been like that when you're in your
marriage maybe that's why I failed
that's how it always is
Brady by the way taking some Revenge
pics of his own oh don't worry
25. you can't wear us that's not sexy
round that down to 25. okay yo that that
[__] scubas like yeah that's pretty
cool you want to do that I've done it
you did I did that's why I'm a certified
scuba diver because I had to I had to be
to get to get there
they wouldn't let you do it unless
you're a certified student yeah so I
wasted all my [__] time on vacation
bro
it's so worth it too it was one of the
coolest things I've ever done in my life
and you go underwater with it yeah
you're just being pulled along like a
James Bond dude you're going like 15
miles an hour so sick
um so yeah Giselle is basically getting
pounded out hard by her yoga instructor
no way and he could probably really
pound hard that's new because he's very
flexible downward dog you know is it a
bigger yoga thing or no no he's doing
mostly head stepping oh like your style
That's My Style yeah yeah double I go
for the neck usually but sometimes I'm
in the yeah sometimes that's a boot on
the on the back of the slips right yeah
yeah I thought you'd do a double leg I
was like the that do ski stereotypical
you just put his foot up
when I'm at the lodge I put a ski on the
background picture doesn't this sound
like every like Rich celebrity Malibu
housewife story she [__] one of her
instructors or something and then like
it really is right yeah but that's the
stereotype yeah instructor the dance
instructor
yeah and then she he gives her attention
she's lonely well and then they
who's the oldest celebrity that you guys
would be down to Market yeah Mark to
Costco's right yeah probably the Clone
Meister how old is the Betty White I
mean not Betty White the [__]
Angelina Jolie's oh she's like [__]
75 years old I [__] that let's go to
Steve for the ages
Meryl Streep I think it's like 122. oh
Meryl Streep Merrell Street's a good one
I would say bro she's 47. I rounded up
I'll say Angela Bassett Angela bass is
still got it I think she's not that old
she might be for real though Angela nah
she's not that old hey James Marsden huh
James Morrison let's get a couple of
those guys in there yeah
like for 64 for sure Rick Rubin Angela
Bassett she's 64. that's what I'm saying
he looks great [__] Diane Feinstein
man [__] Diane feinsteins dude
oh hey
he's not old at all though right yeah he
is how old he I mean he's like what 50
something new
they look good forever man yeah
look at a freaking uh Morgan Freeman
Morgan Freeman he looks he's probably 90
and he looks like you left he got all
the things
his career started when he was like 105.
and he's always wise you know I only
knew him when he was old he didn't crack
as Steve Martin Steve Martin still looks
great oh that's true and I came on the
scene like 25 years old with gray hair
so he's yeah he's a silver fox well
that's probably why we don't feel like
he's older because he looked old yeah he
looked old yeah
sure yeah
yeah I kind of want to
he better have a yoga mat in this
picture yeah or I'm not buying it Steve
flank coach is that really like all yoga
it's very special downward dogs are all
the time yes
we're dogged her hard he does headstands
even while he's going inside yeah he's
from Trinidad Tobago let's top it off
does that even work she's also a
Kamasutra instructor on the side yeah in
a in a smoothie he also has an extent
does it say extensive rap sheet that
erwan does it say he does like more like
hot yogurt he does more like videos yeah
it's hot hot yoga because he does wet
yoga
he looks like a little kid he does new
room massage you know what that is
it's very wet what's that you know what
that is that Japanese it's that Japanese
massage
yeah right freaking perverts I heard he
does the milkings new room massages
where you put like you put like your you
cover your body in lube and then you
just slide around with your whole bottle
that doesn't do it I swear to God that's
real it does left that could be it I
just think it's high that's purely
sexual and who has the tarp for the
cleanest closer they bring it anybody
who's like laying out tarp right before
I have questions man
[Laughter]
because I want everyone to see the Tom
Brady's ex-wife getting slammed by
another guy can I see that's not what
that is
a yoga instructor you know how people
probably imagine like a dreadlock white
dude right but I really hope one day
they say that and it's a fat Indian man
oh that'd be great oh that's cool yeah
because like yeah I was I was [__] my
yoga instructor and then they're like
picturing this this Bohemian white guy
tall you know abs and [__] and then it's
a real yoga Master that's like when
Arnold cheated on his wife with like the
maid yeah
Arnold has a Mexican son she looks like
a real milk drinker
Arnold Schwarzenegger's Mexican son
or the made the milkshake oh for sure
milk Drinker yeah
oh
that's true
whole milk is very is that like is that
like an ancient like a pirate insult
what is that that just like a Grog
guzzler that's a that's a that's a
Roaring Twenties yeah it's a Great
Depression Great Depression itself this
is the lady that Arnold Schwarzenegger
was banging on
that's Metamucil too it's not even about
yeah it's useful that's Activia he was
like this is the oldest I will go that
is the oldest he's like they're good
healthy bones
speaking of [__] did you see how he
came out talking about his dad was a
Nazi yes I mean why that crazy say that
again what Arnold just came out talking
about on CNN he did a whole speech about
his uh his dad was a Nazi they didn't
know that until now that's pretty
impressive well he probably just didn't
disclose it so how would you figure it
out dude but there's no record find
Hitler and found that out I don't know I
always you know what's funny this is
gonna sorry guys if the channel gets
burned down for saying this but like how
do they not know who so many Nazis are
when they can account for every single
Jew in the Holocaust um Fair Point you
probably have to come out or maybe they
just accepted it that's actually her
maybe they just did a better job of
deleting records for Nazis so that they
could like hide that thank you that is a
good answer those are great answers you
got a strong bones that's actually a
really great answer I'm glad I asked
a lot of b-5 a guy who questioned the
whole thing
[Music]
hey 911 the holocausts are different
said the one thing he asked was that we
not make him deny this oh is that what
he said